you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you and catch up with NB. So for a personal discussion or social discussion today, I just went with something basic. What is your favorite hobby? And for me, I'm like a huge TV show watcher. So it's like one of the things my wife and I do when the kids go to bed. So we really like kind of just like situation of comedy. So like shits Creek, arrested development for like a classic one. The office, parks and rack shows like that. We seem to enjoy what we also watch like. Like we were watching Mark Marin stand up. That's on Netflix last night, which is kind of funny. I don't know if I might not be funny to everybody, but we seem to like use very sharp caps that can drive humor. So yeah, that's what we enjoy. I
mean, what about you? Yeah, TV shows. I also like comedy TV shows. I think I watched that 70s show. I don't know how many times like five times or like the eight seasons. And we actually watched the whole eight seasons as well with my girlfriend last year, I think. And yeah, I always love that TV show. And other hobbies, I would say music, playing music. So we are going back to playing music. It's my girlfriend. Now that we have the drum kit in the living room. So that's fun. And as well as I used to practice skateboard quite a lot. I would say about a few years ago, I tried to go back to it, but it's like it's a sport where it's hard to progress. But it's good to just let go and try. You have to try a lot before you actually succeed a little. So yeah, for me music sports TV shows.
Yeah, I would say that's more so. What about your mark? Yeah, TV shows are good. We watch friends. Friends is one of our favorites for a sitcom. But we're watching BLOST at the minute. So it's kind of hard to believe it's, I think it's like 20 years old now. Because I remember watching that at university. And other hobbies, I cook a lot. So we do a lot of cooking. And it's mostly at the minute. Indian food have been learning a lot about Indian food, like the different blends of spices and Thai food as well. I really like Thai food. For some reason, I'm really into really strong flavours. And I find that Indian and Thai food are pretty much the strongest ones. So I really enjoy those. And there's also a lot of vegetarian options in Indian food. Lots of vegetarian recipes. So I spend a lot of my time just tweaking the spice blends to see which ones are best, which is something I enjoy doing. Trying to find the best combination of spices. Sports, I used to really enjoy skiing, but I just haven't really had time to do it recently. And the snow in Scotland hasn't been that great. But yeah, I used to go to France a lot to do skiing and sometimes Bulgaria. But not so much recently. And what about you, Albert? I think for me, I've always been
climbing a lot recently. And the other was like two years ago, exciting for two years ago. And I think this year, I'm cutting down on the climbing. Because I feel that it's been quite taxing on the body. It does. Like the nature of the sport is very, it's very prone to injury. So I'm like I have had a muscle injury last year. So I'm planning to stop for cut down. And it's the frequency of climbing. So I'm trying to go back to what I used to do before that, which is during a lot of running and swimming and cycling. For the past one week and plus, since I came back, I've been trying to do that. But I've been trying to do it like once a day. So hopefully I can get back to what. Doing the levels I used to do. So yeah, like five years ago, I used to do a lot of triathlon. So I was like talking a few hours of training a week. I don't know if I ever get back to that state, but at least get the frequency and the variety of exercises. Because I think one good thing about that is it doesn't take too much note on certain muscle, muscular groups. So there is a lot of changes between different muscle groups. We can still keep the frequency while exercising different types of muscle groups. And they get dressed in between. So for example, if I run to later, I cycle tomorrow, or I swim the next day, then the different muscle groups get arrested. But I'm still keeping up the exercise momentum. So trying to get back to that routine, maybe not in terms of following like number of hours of spend a day. Like then I was doing like one to always a day. I've never thought about that. How a triathlon is pretty
much like a built -in muscle group rotation workout. Yeah, that's that's pretty cool. I used to work out a lot more than I do now. And it would be a lot of rotation of muscle groups. Monday, Monday, do like number body, do say do lower body. Wednesday, maybe isolate on shoulders. And it was just, yeah, that's an interesting way to just kind of keep health like be able to train in a very healthy way versus over the one part of your body. So yeah, cool. Awesome. Well, thanks for sharing everybody. I'm really, um, um, um, Marcus, cool to know that you like cooking too. Uh, I, I love Indian food. That's the thing that like my, my three year olds on, he's really into, uh, right now. So, so I, I'll probably chat with you
about that. Yeah, I've got a lot of recipes if you, if you want to know any. Yeah, a little
chat, we'll chat in one on one. Cool. Okay. So over two announcements. Um, so, um, Remi, uh, Remi has announced right here that he set up a chart to track the number of, um, review up deployments for day and you need to review up deployments for day. Um, thank you for doing that. Remi, I know we chatted about that in our one -on -one. And, um, you know, it was like 20 minutes later. It is what it felt like it was there. Uh, so that's super helpful. Thank you very much. Um, and then for me, this is more of like a, uh, GitLab announcement. So contribute 2020 has officially been canceled. You haven't seen. Um, if you need help, um, or have any questions on canceling, canceling your flights entering your voucher, um, details or refund details in the credit form, uh, see the issue. You can also ask me to be more than happy to help. Um, for those of you that were that did have flights, um, that's pretty important to, um, make sure that GitLab can recoup any, any costs related to flights. Any other announcements that anyone has? Okay. Um, first I know my head was just checking in on the really apologizing first. So I'm sorry that, um, last week's meeting, I didn't catch the daylight saving time. Really impacted pretty much everybody. Um, so when I came back from vacation, uh, there wasn't daylight saving time there. So I just did like, like a few hours of time adjustment and it wasn't top of mind. So my apologies that this time, the current time meeting may not work the best. Um, I was going to see if there's another time that worked. It looks like Albert proposed an hour later. Um, and I think that works for me. Um, does that work for Mark, Remy? Does that work for
you as well? Yeah, this, this always happens at this time of year. There's just like a shift and then everyone's confused for like two weeks and it shifts back and everyone's confused again. And, um, go ahead. But, um, yeah, the calendar is usually updated themselves, but if you used to stock at a certain time in your day, it's usually, um, different, but I agree with Remy. It's, it's in the middle of my day. So whatever works
for everyone. Okay. I'll check with you in for me. Go ahead Albert. Sorry. I think, um, again, do I
like after, so what I want to do from now onwards, I think it's best. Um, but if, if, if it's going to be challenging for you, call then, um, maybe we can consider a different timing. Um, I think it's just excellent. Except not this kind of. Oh, it's okay. It's just, it's, it might be challenging at some,
in some weeks for me. Yeah. So I'll be like later in a day. Yeah. I wasn't clear in that comment. Um, I may, like, I guess what I mean is like, my daughter will probably be here then. So my wife will take my son to school. I'll keep my daughter. So I may be a little bit more distracted than I am right now. Um, but I think in an hour from now, it works great. I'll check with Shinshin, um, and our one -on -one later in the week and confirm with him. But, um, yeah, thank you for. Thanks for kind of like having the discussion on this async. So I'll look to get it rescheduled next week after I chat with Shinshin on Thursday. Yeah. Um, Remy, over to you on interruptable jobs. Yeah. Um,
so yeah, I implemented the interruptible jobs, um, I suggested, um, by Josh initially, I think. And I also implemented the, the work around, uh, proposed by Shinshin to, um, to have, uh, basically all the jobs are interruptible by default, um, except one job, which I called don't interrupt me, um, at the moment. Um, and this job that runs automatically in master, so that, um, by plans in master won't be interrupted, um, as today, um, because we don't, since master is getting a lot of updates, we don't want by plans to be constantly cancelled and never have a finished by plans there. Um, and this job is manually in merge request so that if, uh, you need to push like a change and you definitely want, uh, a current pipeline that is running to finish, uh, even, uh, even after you push the new change, then you can just start the job, uh, to, uh, to, uh, not make the, the current pipeline uh, concerned. Um, and yeah, I've, uh, so that was quite simple to implement, uh, so I was, uh, uh, surprised on a, in a good way. Uh, and, um, I also added a validation part to the issue, to, uh, with, uh, three things that, uh, that should, uh, like, three charts that should, uh, go down, basically, like the cost, um, the cost charts, two cost charts, and one chart about council pipelines, which should go up, actually, like, consent pipelines in merge request. Um, and yeah, that, that's it. Um, I don't know if there's, uh, any things more to say. No, I think it looks really exciting. Um, thanks
for adding the validation portion to the issue so that we can, um, keep it open. I, I like that we've been doing that more and more. I think the last, uh, few milestones where it's, we'll make a change, we'll monitor the make sure it has the, um, the intended impact on whatever metric that were that kind of like started it. So, um, quantitative feedback loop that, that's, that's good. Um, um, this, was this in, like, the
engineering we can review, or have we sought feedback on this at all? No. Um, so this isn't merge yet. Um, this is, this still needs a review, um, by Genshin. Okay. Um, so yeah, and, and I will definitely announce it once it's merged. I, I don't want to, for this one, I, I don't want to, to ask for feedback before because I think we know that we want to do it. And I know that some, I already know that I mean, I think some people will, will, be like, we don't like it because they like to have each commit tested. But I don't think it's a good, it's a good rationale because I mean, in the end, what we care about is, if the merge request is, is, is basing. So, um, and the Genshin just plays a job if they really want to have, uh, back and forth commits. I see. Yeah. I, I
would agree that I think from a feedback perspective, we'll get the sending of it. Go ahead, Robert. Um, like
if someone wants every commit, uh, every push, to be tested, um, I don't think the CI pipeline gives a very good feedback product because like, you've got a pipeline, it's 45 minutes and it's too, complete. Um, if someone, someone were to say that they want to get, uh, every commit tested, it's not very realistic, because, yeah, the feedback doesn't come as immediate to commit. Yeah. Yeah. This is still, like, we're still managing to, um, the MR
as a whole. Yeah, I agree. Um, yeah, I think some people like try, like want to, want to push, like commits and make sure that pipeline spits for like, like, they, they want to build on passing changes. Basically, I think that's our, they think, um, but, um, yeah, I mean, if you push many commits in, like, in, uh, you know, one hour time time span, let's say, then it doesn't make sense to run, um, many pipelines. So I think it's, uh, I mean, it's a good default, I think. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I, I would agree.
Um, maybe, uh, well, yeah. The only thing I was thinking is in the issue, if we could just say, like, um, you know, maybe specify just like some background information, like this, how much current is currently spent on the GitLab pipeline, and we're, yeah, like this is part of the reduction of that number, so that, um, any, any individual who goes into the issue, it doesn't have to click on the chart. And then it makes it very clear. But I think it makes it clearer. Um, it kind of like, like, cost savings measure or not.
So, yeah, it's already the, like, the first rationale in the issue, but I will, I will, uh, it's, I will add charts and, uh, and make sure it's, uh, okay. I'm, I am very excited to see how this
impacts costs, because I think, like you said, it's hard, it's, it was hard for me to quantify how many, um, pipelines are run for an MR that are almost simultaneous executions to see what could be cut down from this, but I'm excited to see what that number looks like. Um, so yeah, good work. Awesome work on this.
I have comments about the validation charts. Um, so, okay. That is chess, isn't tracking on the kid, kid, like mirror as well as, um, package, uh, kid, like, you know, kill that QA, um, the pipelines, the pipelines on those projects, because as we cancel, and we, as we have this in place, and we can sell more in progress pipelines than those, the number of pipelines that is run in those projects will also go down. So, I
think we good to see how, um, the other two downstream projects affected. Yeah, and, and maybe, so I just, so I just look quickly at the charts that we have in the, in France, here, usage, dashboard, but maybe there's other charts that are, um, more, um, more precise, I would say, and maybe you can even like create
the dedicated charts because, um, like, I think, yeah, yeah, um, so I, I think the GitLab .com shared runner estimated cost by project internal only. If you click the GitLab, it's there. Yeah, yeah, I was going to say, yeah, QA, omnibus, GitLab near everything's there. And if you click the top, like the GitLab button, it hides it, and then you can see the portion, proportion of everything else. Right. So we could still monitor it. Yeah, of course. It's a little bit more challenging, but we should be able to have, at least see. Yeah, good, good,
fine, good, fine, cool. That's a good question now. Yeah, yeah, very good question. Any other questions on that? Um,
Albert, over to you. Sorry, the next one. Sorry, Albert, I think we've got Remy off right there. Yeah, and
yeah, I know I was just going through to say that I will add these details to the issue, like, like we expect the just to go down for GitLab omnibus GitLab mirror, and this kind of project, like the
downstream project. That's it. Go ahead. I'm okay. Sorry about that, Albert. Yeah, the next item is on the review app. So, um, this is touching what's called earlier today. But then the next thing we want to do is start looking at operating the Helm Tree. I did some of the investigations, so we are, we could actually run Helm Tree and Helm 2 in parallel, like, Helm 2 and Helm 3 deploy into the same cluster and M space. So, I'm curious what discussions have been done before, or any previous investigations. Some of the existing issues and discussion from the distribution group is there, and this is from Karl, a little bit. So, I'm just trying to get any other, if there's any other discussions that I'm not seeing, or I'm not aware of, feel free to
bring it up, then I'll take a look at it. Yeah, one thing that I have in mind is that we also need to update the CI image, and I think we are using, like, we are sharing the image, like, the charts project, and our review apps jobs are using the same image, so that's something to keep in mind as well, I think. Yeah. Chops, you are referring to a spot project. Yeah, the chart, chart, GitLab project.
Yeah, okay. I don't think we know that. Yeah. And that was actually going to be the thing that I asked when you were talking about doing home two and home three at the same time, I think, whether it's in our image, and I think there's some steps where we check to see if, like, tillers installed and install it, like, like, there's some home two specific steps in our setup. So, we have to handle that logic in our review app script, depending on where it's running, so that's the other thing, kind of keep in mind. Yeah. I'm, so, Remi, I thought that there was an issue to upgrade review apps at home three, but I couldn't find it when I was talking with Albert earlier. Do you know what there was one created, or the other thing I thought of was, maybe it was just thinking of the distribution team's issues. Yeah, no, I don't think
we have an issue of others. Okay. Yeah. Okay. That's good to know that. And I was thinking also related, not directly related, but on the topic of review apps, I think we should also update the charts version through the latest, because I think there were some improvements to the charts, so that could, that could have. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I'm excited to see how this evolves. I am. I've only used Humphrey. The fresh. So I don't have a lot of experience upgrading, like a cluster that was on Humphrey. So I unfortunately don't have like firsthand gotchas. I can do some, you know, like, I think there's some good base information on Helms website. That's like kind of like a path for upgrading and things like that, which I'm sure you've already tracked down. I'm excited to
see how this comes together. Anything else on this one for me or Mark? I'm just wondering if there's, so it's not clear, I haven't looked at all the issues yet, but is there, I think the current charts should work with the, with a client that's using Humphrey, right? That's the thing that's been one of the problems that Jason made the chart itself. Yeah. It's comfortable. Yeah. Okay, so on this side, cool. So that means we don't, yeah, we can investigate updating just, yeah, for the R review apps deployments. So maybe we can, since we are sharing the same image, maybe we should like split the images one for M2, the current one and create a new one with M3 so that we can test on our sides without affecting other projects. Yeah, thanks. Okay, I
appreciate it. Okay, and the last item that I had, I thought I got some good feedback from my candidate that I was interviewing, who said there's not much unfiltered content for the engineering productivity team, and I was like, oh, that's great feedback. And they specifically called out they were like, well, there's the video for insights, and then there's a lot of quality, there's some quality department, but not much engineering productivity team. And I thought that was, like, good feedback and an opportunity to, to get better here. So I thought of just starting with uploading this meeting, recording of this meeting to get live unfiltered, but I was curious if anyone else had an idea on videos that we could create or just kind of record as things happen that would provide that that would help provide just kind of like insight into how we work and our team. Definitely. Yeah, I think like review apps
are a good good topic in general, because I think that could also help internally for people to understand how review apps are set up, and so that because it's often that people ask why the review app is failing
or they don't get the whole picture. So I think that could help. Another suggestion would be like how I think we can have pipelines itself, the configuration that we're using, if maybe yeah. Because I have got questions from other people about how to use the CI conflict. Yeah, so. It's really useful for the public as well. And
I'm thinking also danger would be a good good topic because same thing like people don't have a good idea. Like there's a few parts in danger. Like there's the the roulette. Like people sometimes they confuse the roulette in danger. Oh yeah, there's a few parts like there's the roulette. There's the there's also the part where there are another thing in danger, currently where on specific changes, specific teams are things, but it's not the roulette. It's just like another kind of things. And then just like the code owners file, which is also like giving suggestion for our ProVels, which and all of that is trading sometimes a bit of a mess. So maybe there's something to explain better here. And I think in the end it's mostly the product that needs to be improved. But yeah,
I mean, yeah, that's some videos to be done probably. Anything else? My plan so kind of pull these into one large issue and see what we can collaborate on async and work towards creating. I think we had an
issue about potential blog posts for the quality team. Well, the quality department, but before it was so big. So I think that's hanging around somewhere which has some other ideas, which we could instead do as a video. Yeah,
good call. I'll try and find. And I think we could also probably speak about metrics like how we use them, how we detect problems and use the metrics to validate changes that we do. Something like that. Yeah. You're the topics that we have in the, in the end book page for the team. Yeah, and that's kind of
what I was thinking. It would be nice to really refresh our handbook content and kind of do it with some videos. One of the software engineers and tests in a coffee chat also mentioned that is, they were like, well, it looks like the engineering productivity team does a lot of work, but I don't really have a good understanding of like what it, like how work is, is like determined or really what it is. So, you know, I was really, when the candidate mentioned it, I was, like, I thought, oh, this could even have benefits externally, where we don't even have an opportunity to really clarify. Whereas in the internal candidate, they can always ask and we can always jump in and then document that in the handbook afterwards. But, um, cool. Okay. So, I'll, like I said, I'll pull this into, I don't want to dog file on the blog post issue, but maybe extract some ideas like you suggested Mark from there and create an issue for this. And then yeah, we can just see how it, see how it evolves. I'll start uploading this meeting, the recording of our team meetings up to get live on filtered as well. And see if I can, see if I can create like a playlist. I haven't done a lot of stuff on get or on YouTube, but I'm sure it's not too hard just to like combine all of our team meetings into one one group. So, awesome. Great discussion on that. I'll make sure I note the action item. Anything else that anyone wants to bring out? Okay. Okay. Thank you for the time and the great discussion. I appreciate it. And also thanks for the great agenda items that we added. I think this meeting went a lot more efficiently than the past few ones. So, I hope everyone has a good rest of your day and stay safe in these really stressful and anxious times. So, can you all A, C, okay?
Sure. Thanks. Have a great day. Bye.